salignac comme bonjour et merci d'être
en direct avec nous alors l'exécutif a
déjà refusé de nationaliser plusieurs
sites industriels en danger quelle peut
être la stratégie de l'état pour accéder
justement à cette souveraineté
internationale voulue par emmanuel
macron stratégie relativement simple il
faut d'un côté effectivement protéger
les entreprises existantes la dire si
nécessaire les subventionner si
nécessaire leur apporter des faux port
et si nécessaire éviter qu'elle passe
sous contrôle étranger parce que
lorsqu'une entreprise passe contrôle
étranger les risques sont grands dieux
quelques années plus tard d'entreprises
étrangères décident de délocaliser sa
production est par ailleurs dans le cas
spécifique de l'industrie pharmaceutique
il faut assurer des prix un peu plus
rémunérateurs à ces entreprises pour
certains produits de manière à ce qu
effectivement elle dispose des moyens
financiers pour produire pour produire
en france
quel serait le montant de l enveloppe
pour m pour tenter de mettre fin à la
dépendance sanitaires tant mieux déclare
le chef de l'état vous savez que dans le
plan de relance il a été prévu
malheureusement un milliard pour
l'ensemble des industries sur trois ans
sun sur trois ans est bien sûr
totalement insuffisant une faudrait ou
1,5 milliards rien que pour l'industrie
pharmaceutique si effectivement on se
lance dans un vaste plan qui comporte à
la fois l'industrie par abba
pharmaceutiques mais également
l'ensemble des dispositifs médicaux
comme les seringues comme des appareils
de réanimation c'est un effort qui doit
être fait qui doit se
chez les industriels et les tags qui
suppose que les industriels acceptent
une sorte de tutelle de l'état pour
planifier leurs activités at on déjà une
idée justement des bénéfices économiques
à la relocalisation sites de production
on pense notamment à la production de
médicaments
la question du bénéfice économique est
relativement complexe c'est à dire que
bien sûr la facilité c'est pas de
produire en europe ce n'est pas de
produire en force à la facilité c'est
d'importer des produits aux pays à bas
salaires
c'est production dans ce pays moins cher
mais en contrepartie les comores comores
comme on le sait on a plus aucun
contrôle sur la qualité
on n'a qu'à plein d'un contrôle limité
sur la qualité des produits et on n'a
aucun contrôle sur disponibilité à un
quad que lorsqu'il ya une crise mondiale
cette crise par définition de mort de
rose de la production pour fournir
l'ensemble des pays du monde et rien
n'indique que effectivement les pays
européens soit plus rippert c'est pour
ça que le grand avantage c'est avant
tout un avantage de la court terme
c'est un avantage de disponibilité et
puis c'est comme pour toutes les
industries à voir la production en
france
ça permet aussi de développer la
recherche en france ça permet de
conserver et du menthe et nos
compétences en la matière et
effectivement ça peut être extrêmement
intéressant si demain ben y'a d'autres
pics ya d'autres pandémies ceux qui se
déclenche un peu notre course a montré
la crise sanitaire c'est que à l'avenir
compte tenu la dégradation de la
biodiversité on court le risque
d'appareils auditifs de ce genre de
pandémie dont il est très important
d'avoir les moyens de plus poster de
façon autonome en france merci beaucoup
henri sterdyniak d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
c'est plein d'amis
aloès